today we're gonna make boring bubbles
or are we first we squirt liquid soap
into water next we dissolve 11 grams of
sodium hydrogen sulfate in 100
milliliters of water the sodium hydrogen
sulfate will provide a source of
hydrogen ions and we can give those ions
some electrons they will pair up and
form hydrogen gas some magnesium metal
will do just that
now I'm going to stop her this up and
I'm going to send the gas into our soapy
water the soap and water will trap the
gas into cute bubbles if you think
explosive hydrogen gas is cute we'll let
the bubbles accumulate for a while all
right should we light them
[Music]
stuff like this with your kids awesome I
got you I don't just work for the
Curiosity box I also work for Mel
science you can get everything you need
to do stuff like this in our chemistry
course and you know what you want 60 off
your first kit use code corn dog